So the bad news will just not stop coming
for Donald Trump.
A bombshell New York Times article this week
yesterday, in fact, revealing that Donald
Trump has an undisclosed bank account in China
and it exposes a whole series of Chinese business
pursuits.
This is, of course, the same Donald Trump
that has been going after China for the virus
and going after China for doing this and that
unfair thing to the United States.
The same Donald Trump that has been repeating
for months that if Joe Biden were to be president,
China would control Biden.
The same Trump whose Republican Party has
been going after Joe Biden's son, Hunter Biden,
for opening a bank account in China that Donald
Trump has a bank account in China and a long
history of trying to do business with China.
The New York Times has continued to analyze
the tax records that were the basis for the
blockbuster story about trumping no federal
taxes in 10 of the last 15 years from a few
weeks ago, which feels like years ago, by
the way.
That story was just a few weeks ago.
And The New York Times has now learned that
Donald Trump has bank accounts in Britain,
in Ireland and, yes, in China.
The Chinese bank account shocker was not on
Donald Trump's public financial disclosures
because it's held under a convenient corporate
name.
And that Chinese bank account paid one hundred
and eighty eight thousand dollars in taxes
to the Chinese government between 2013 and
2015.
Understand that that means Trump's business
paid more tax to the Chinese government in
those years than Trump paid in the United
States federally.
And Donald Trump is saying Biden has the China
problem.
And we know that Trump projects all the time.
Trump accuses others of being corrupt when
he's corrupt.
Trump accuses others of nepotism when he's
the king of nepotism.
Trump accuses others of receiving softball
interviews when he gets weekly softball interviews
from Fox and Friends and Sean Hannity and
Maria Bartiromo and Eric Bolling yesterday
and the whole cast at Fox News.
But this is another level of projection, with
China claiming for weeks now that Hunter Biden
has this and that financial connection to
China.
And it's a problem for Joe Biden and so on.
And all along, Donald Trump has had an undisclosed
Chinese bank account.
And this puts a huge list of actions related
to China under the microscope once again.
Many Chinese government proposals came after
Trump became president.
Yvonne could trump one Chinese trademark approvals
for her.
Was it clothing or handbags after she joined
the White House staff?
And on and on and on.
And all of these now need to be scrutinized
under a new light.
Not that they didn't need to be scrutinized
before.
It's a perfect amalgam of possible nepotism,
cronyism and corruption, which I don't think
we will ever know the full scope of.
I know there's this idea that after Trump
leaves, whether it's in in, you know, a few
months or in four years, there will be investigations
and will eventually get to the bottom of it.
I don't think we will.
And let me just give you one more example.
And again, each one of these examples could
be a huge story, a major investigation by
itself.
And I assure you, if this was a story about
Chelsea Clinton during a Hillary presidency
instead of about Ivanka, it would be a huge
story.
This from the same New York Times investigation
says, quote, Not long after winning the 2016
election, Mr. Trump reported selling a penthouse
in one of his Manhattan buildings for fifteen
point eight million dollars to a Chinese American
businesswoman named Shao Yan Chen, who bought
the unit previously occupied by Ivonka Trump
and her husband, Jared Kushner, in an off
market transaction.
Ms Chen runs an international consulting firm
and reportedly has high level connections
to government and political elites in China.
Circumstantially, that is as much of a red
flag or more ripe for investigation than anything
that we have about Hunter, Biden and Joe Biden
right now by itself.
That sale could be a huge story to investigate.
But again, we may never know the full scope
of what's gone down and what favors have been
offered and done in exchange for what one
of you e-mailed me about this story saying.
What is the breaking point for Trump supporters
and for Republicans with this stuff?
Republican congressmen all know Trump may
be tied to all of these different countries.
What's the breaking point?
The answer is we're 13 days away from the
election.
There is no breaking point if Trump wins.
They.
Win, in a sense.
And they just try to maintain power.
If Trump loses, they start to distance themselves
from Trump.
Pretend they never really supported him.
He wasn't really a Republican and move on.
And you could apply that prediction not just
to Republican elected officials, but just
your average run of the mill Trump supporter.
And we will see what The New York Times has
in the next 13 days based on these documents.